there are a hundred million forcibly
displaced people in the world
if they had their own country it would
be the 15th biggest in the world larger
than vietnam turkey and germany
[Music]
by country the biggest crisis in the
world right now is the ukraine war
accounting for 14 million people who've
had to leave their homes
after ukraine syrians make up the second
largest population of refugees today at
6.8 million people
there are 5.8 million palestinians
forcibly displaced
this is the world's longest running
refugee crisis
and decades of war in afghanistan have
forcibly displaced 2.6 million people
who hosts the most refugees
turkey is home to the most refugees in
the world followed by jordan colombia
uganda and pakistan predominantly low
and middle income countries
many of the refugees end up in camps
like this one the kutapalong refugee
camp in cox's bazar bangladesh
home to rohingya refugees fleeing
persecution in myanmar since 1997
it's become the world's largest refugee
camp with around 1 million people there
other huge camps include dadaab in kenya
home to 220 000 people
kakuma also in kenya where about 185 000
people live
and the zattari camp in jordan home to
76 000 people
but is the worst yet to come
with a hundred million people displaced
in 2022 the un warns that climate change
and other crises could force another 1
billion people from their homes by 2050.
[Music]